-First of all, congratulations.
This film is so fantastic.
-Thank you so much!
-You co-wrote it, you starred
in it, you directed it.
-Yes.
-You have directed things
before.
You've never directed horror
before, though?
-No.
-And --
-Why would I do that?
-Yeah, I mean --
[ Laughter ]
It didn't seem like a fit
for me either.
But it's the number-one movie
in the country.
How did it come about?
How did this --
-It was really interesting.
I was about to start this show
"Jack Ryan" that I was doing,
and some of the producers
had this script, and they said,
"Would you ever act
in a horror movie?"
And I said, "Ooh, I don't do
horror, but thanks anyway."
And they said,
"It's about a family that
can't make any noise,
and you have to figure out why."
And I went, "Damn it!" That's
one of the best one-liners ever.
[ Laughter ]
And I read this script,
and legitimately, yes,
I love that everybody says
it's scary, and it is.
It's really great, but there
was something in there,
the deeper theme there
is parenthood.
And I actually was holding
our 3-week-old daughter
while reading this script
about a family
that would do anything
to protect their kids,
and I was like, "Oh, my God."
-Yeah.
-I was using the baby
to wipe the tears.
Which, by the way, we have
to talk about your baby!
-Well, I -- you know,
I do want to say --
-No!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you, guys. Thank you.
-And don't worry,
I'll bring it full circle
back to the movie.
I'm selfish.
-Yeah, no, I want to tie it in.
-I want to talk about
this lobby hero you became.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, look, I --
my wife was the hero,
but I -- it does tie in
to the movie because
I would have thought
the most terrifying birth
this weekend was --
there's a birth in this movie.
-Yeah.
-You know, this is a movie
about you have to be quiet
or else the monsters.
-Yeah.
-And so Emily has to do a scene
where she's birthing
without making a noise.
-Yeah.
-It's terrifying.
-And then your wife,
your actual wife gives birth
in the lobby, and you're like,
"That was nothing."
[ Laughter ]
Because you think
monsters are scary,
but nothing's more scary
than like,
"Oh, my God, our doorman
is going to see
my wife's genitals."
-Okay, so --
[ Laughter ]
So wait, I just --
I thought about that doorman
when you were telling the story.
-Yeah.
-Because you sort of
skipped past him.
-Yeah.
-You were like,
"There's a doorman --" and then
you thanked him very nicely.
But I just imagined
what that guy's doing, like,
"Hey, Seth, how you doing?"
"You guys go" --
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, my God, it's a baby.
Oh, it's a baby.
That's a baby
in your sweat pants!"
Like, did you shut him down
forever?
-I got to be honest.
And I hope he doesn't
take this the wrong way --
I wasn't focused on him.
[ Laughter ]
Like, during the birth...
-It's fine.
-...I was like,
"I hope Kevin's okay."
[ Laughter ]
No, but it was --
they were great
because I only know
they were great, like,
after the fact because
they did, like,
kind of corral the people
in our building to be like,
"You can't go in the lobby
right now."
-Yeah, they were like,
"There's wet here. It's wet.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, it's wet.
Just careful, careful."
-But it's like --
It's a beautiful wet.
[ Laughter ]
But yeah, so --
-Oh, that's my band name.
-It was -- it was --
[ Laughter ]
-My new band name.
-Oh, but you know --
you mentioned you had
a 3-week-old.
You got a 4-year-old
and a 2-year-old.
-Yes. Almost 2.
-Almost 2.
So we got a two-year gap
with ours, as well.
What is --
how is the second one --
how did it change the game?
-In every single way.
-Yeah.
-Because the --
when you have your first child,
it's amazing, but in
those moments where
your, like, brain
starts twitching,
you get to go, "Can you
hold her for a second?"
And there's someone to do that.
And now you go,
"Can you hold her? Who's this?"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-I'm like, "Number two
gets passed to you."
And there's no break.
-Yeah.
-I just FaceTimed
right before the show
with my wife and it was
just both kids and the dog.
And she was laughing
like the Joker.
[ Laughter ]
Like, so, like, she was happy
and smiling, but, like,
the way you do before you,
like, poison a city's water.
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-That's called new parenthood.
-That's what I tapped into
in the movie.
-You did! But you
really genuinely did
tap into movie because --
I mean,
obviously, you and Emily
play parents,
which you are in real life.
The kids -- you cast
the most wonderful kids.
-Unbelievable.
-Yeah.
-I've always been told
don't work with kids.
They never know their lines
and they have kid hours,
which are shorter than yours.
And they're not professional.
I had the exact opposite
experience.
These kids are --
I probably slowed them down.
-Yeah.
-They're the most professional
kids in the world.
And we had --
-And you didn't even give them
any lines?
-No.
-You put them in a movie
where they're not allowed
to talk.
-I didn't. Yeah.
-Yeah.
I was like,
"Oh, you think you're good?
How about this? No dialogue.
[ Laughter ]
Deal with that, kid!
Oh, you did deal with it.
Oh, wow! You did very well."
-And, I mean, did you just know?
I mean, I'm guessing you
cast a wide net
of trying to find kids
to play in this film.
Did you know
when you found them, like,
"Oh, these are the ones."
-Oh, instantaneously.
Yeah, so, Noah Jupe,
who plays my son in the movie,
is unbelievable.
He was in "The Night Manager",
and he had just worked with
George Clooney.
And so I e-mailed George --
[Chuckles]
and I just thought...
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, George."
And then he was like,
"Don't ever write here again."
I was like, "Oh, wow!"
[ Laughter ]
No, and he just said
he was the best child actor
he's ever worked with.
And he said,
"And as Doug Ross from 'ER,'
I've worked with them all."
-Yeah, that's --
-Literally.
-Yeah.
-And then the other unbelievable
actress is Milli,
and she is a deaf actress.
She's the most beautiful girl
in the world.
-She's fantastic.
-It was nonnegotiable for me
to cast a deaf actress,
but I had no idea
how lucky I would I get.
We're pretty sure --
Emily and I are sure
that she's not from here,
that she's like an angel
we got to know.
-Yeah.
-She's one of the most --
[ Audience "awws" ]
It's true.
-Yeah.
-Wait till you meet her.
-Yay!
No, I'm just kidding.
[ Laughter ]
But, no, she was such
an unbelievable guide
and spirit animal for the movie.
And she was just the most
beautiful person to be around.
-You got --
This must be really nice
when you have a movie come out.
Like, these are friends
and not people you don't know.
Ryan Reynolds tweeted about
how he'd seen "A Quiet Place."
He wanted you guys
to be his new parents.
-Yes.
-I think that's
very high praise.
This one's pretty good.
LeBron James wanted to go
see it with his wife.
-King Jim.
-And then said,
"#HorrorHouseWeHave."
[ Laughter ]
I'm like -- when he does
something, I'm like,
"That's so much cooler
than I would have done."
Yeah. And then -- but this is
really the highlight, right?
-This was mental. Yeah.
-Stephen King.
-"A Quiet Place" is an
extraordinary piece of work.
Terrific acting, but the main
thing is the silence,
and how it makes the camera's
eyes open wide."
I mean, as a director,
like, that's straight up
the King of Horror...
-Literally the King of Horror.
-...complimenting your choices
as a director.
-No, it was -- it was --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
-Thank you very much. Thank you.
-Yeah.
-No, but then he wrote me
an e-mail,
and one of my favorite things
was I said,
"Oh, my God, you're also
the biggest Red Sox fan."
And he said,
"If you ever want my tickets..."
And I was like...
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So, yeah, that's happening.
-That's fantastic.
This keeps working out
better and better for you.